astro
bring this sippy cup to the living room
[Music]
thank you asheville
one house one tech friendly family and
one eager new robot the amazon astro
that wants nothing more than to become a
member of the family
okay astro out of my way so is this
autonomous all seeing alexa on wheels
worthy of becoming the next addition to
your family
i did not anticipate that reviewing
amazon's new one thousand dollar
invite-only robot was going to cause so
much
drama excitement and
privacy questions in my home to put it
to the test we designed four challenges
all which aim to test astros tech and
ability to bond with humans
[Music]
and pets of all ages astro come
everything it attempts smile will be
judged by joanna stern who's known for
telling it like it is her device reviews
this house is so loud
and a robot has not made it any quieter
astro
your first challenge is to learn to
co-exist in our busy space
you need to do this without harming my
wife are you a fan of astro michelle
no my two kids and my dog
nervous
me too
astro has various stereo depth
navigation and obstacle sensors that
allow it to autonomously navigate its
surroundings
when you first set it up astro does a
full tour to learn your space
starting exploration please move a few
feet back okay it can't do stairs so
it's only one level then you tell it
which room is which this is the living
room it creates a map in the astro app
and you can rename each space
honestly astro learned where things are
in the house faster than my
mother-in-law
and astra might be a better driver than
her too ah nice stop
there have been a couple of times where
astro seems like it's just driving drunk
having a hard time figuring out where it
is i'll let it
figure it out for a second
you can also enable a facial recognition
feature look to your left
go find joanna a robot that's always
looking for your face
it can be creepy so i called up amazon's
dave limp to ask exactly where the data
goes we first looked for a human blob
all locally and then secondly we if if
you've trained your face
we can then greet you by name that's all
processed locally
none of that goes to the cloud the
vector doesn't go to cloud nothing you
can also turn off all mics cameras and
sensors by pressing this button
coexist challenge
pass
astro we do not have any freeloaders in
this house your challenge will be to
chip in and help out with chores i wish
astro would actually talk back but he
just makes these sounds
when you ask it a question that needs an
audible response you get alexa
what's the weather today the current
weather is 30 degrees fahrenheit with
cloudy skies
astro has this little container back
here with the charging port this cup
holder fits on top too
the only problem is is that astro
doesn't have arms to put things in the
cup holder
astro
go to the living room
astro has a hangout feature where the
robot will proactively go to the spaces
it knows you frequent so it's right
there to help
multiple times a day astra just decides
it's going to get off its charging
station and go hang out in the center of
the kitchen
to your charging station go back to the
charger station go to your charging
station you can turn off the hangout
feature and an amazon spokeswoman says
the company is working on improving it
and every time i just see astro sitting
around
and astro
is in its normal spot i wonder why
aren't you cleaning the floors like all
the other household robots the solution
to all of our problems time's around
we dragged all the dirt into the kitchen
where now somebody will have to pick it
up chores challenge
fail
astro i'm going out for a while patrol
and make sure the home stays secure
astro has a periscope with a 12
megapixel camera and then another 5
megapixel camera with ir leds for low
light it also has a 5 megapixel camera
on the screen through the astro app you
can see a view of those cameras and send
the robot to different parts of the
house to see what's going on
if you have a ring protect pro plan you
can set astro to away mode and it will
patrol and be on the lookout for people
it doesn't know
and so there was only one thing to do
[Music]
where are my eyes
i'm going in
[Music]
oh what are you
what are you gonna do you're gonna
punch me i'm stealing things
took a shoe
this kid's shoe
okay if i was a real bad guy i'd
probably just do this
there ha okay to be fair i got an alert
on my phone during all of this that
there was a possible intruder and from
there i could turn on this
still astra's stuck on one floor it can
be buggy and i feel like my security
system and ring doorbell have us covered
so while it was close
patrol challenge
fail
astro your challenge will be to babysit
our four-year-old good luck astro is
really an echo show on wheels alexa can
video call play videos and even games
and like an echo you can put it in kids
mode to make sure it only displays
age-appropriate content set limits etc
the kids
love
astro astro
we are not buying the extreme farts
extension pack
i can play pokemon
i will play pokemon one second i want a
video call with you real quick is that
show a good babysitter no he's not even
babysitting
oh there goes this challenge
but really it's very good with the kids
babysit challenge
pass astro this is a tough decision the
kids love you and you're one of the most
advanced consumer gadgets i've seen in
years
but right now you just don't do enough
to be vital to our household
perhaps by the time amazon releases you
to a broader group of people you'll have
earned that spot in our household
the family is going to miss you dearly
good boy
but i've come up with some ways to
replace you
tune in next time for astro gem two
friends hello